you're such a fantastic voice it's very
unique you have a unique voice what did
you did you have a unique voice as a
child I did it's been very helpful now
like boys and cartoons and things like
that yes but in the past it didn't
really work out that well I worked at a
bank call center and a lot of times
people call me and I'd be like oh thank
you for calling but cobia it's Ron
Funches how can I help you in anybody oh
thank you so much Rhonda you sound like
a wonderful lady then I go oh you are so
right thank you for coming you go with
it I will go with it yeah Rhonda has
some great calls we had great
conversations so now how did you like
the job I hated it you didn't like it no
because I worked at a bank and I just
people were always like giving me my
money back and I'd be like I can't give
it back to you but then I secretly would
and that's how I got fired wait a minute
you would give people their money back
oh yeah it was fun even though you
weren't supposed to know so what would
happen they would say oh I want my money
back and then you'd say well that's not
our policy and then it would make very
strong points I mean like hey over only
over drew by like $2 you guys gave me
$90 and fees and I'd be like yeah we did
that we bangs be doing that and then I
go back and I give them back their fees
and sometimes I find old ones from years
back and I give those back too cuz then
it's like Oh a surprise you go back to
your bank Oh like I got $60 back but I
was like no you got $500 back
Oh Rhonda how long were you doing that
for
Oh it took about the nine months before
they found out and so what happened when
they found out
oh they fired me oh yeah yeah yes okay
all right that's their job is to keep
that money yeah and I wasn't going with
that yeah
bless you Yeah right you were Robin Hood
yeah well I just like my whole life kind
of grew up in this whole thing I was
like I don't like banks I think they're
still in our money and then I worked at
a bank and I was like whoa I was right
okay well why you didn't mention the
name of the bank
what Colby a bank
okay wow that's a commercial we're not
getting still got those Folgers people
though don't get me started on both
punches that far away going up my hair
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you